[Musique]
Québec Solidaire est parti sur le
sentier électoral l'automne dernier
convaincu de pouvoir aspirer à former la
prochaine opposition officielle or les 5
semaines de campagne ce sont soldés par
un seul député solidaire de plus un
résultat a décevant qui est au cœur des
débats du week-end au Conseil Général
poste électoral de la formation
politique à Montréal c'est là que je
retrouve le leader parlementaire de
Québec solidaire Gabriel nado Dubois
merci d'être avec nous monsieur Nadaud
Dubois ça me fait plaisir bonjour
monsieur Thibault si vous aviez un
maître la main je sais que vous avez
parlé de la performance électorale
si vous avez un maître le doigt sur un
élément qui explique la la
contre-performance de votre partie quel
serait-il
je pense qu'il faut nuancer je pense que
je parlerai pas d'une contre-performance
on est le seul parti d'opposition qui a
ajouté un député dans son focus deux
autres parties d'opposition ont perdu
beaucoup beaucoup de députés mais c'est
clair que les résultats étaient pas à la
hauteur de nos attentes ça je vous le
conseille tout à fait puis une des
raisons pour ça c'est qu'on a pas réussi
à connecter suffisamment avec les
électeurs et les électrices qui sont en
dehors des centres urbains au Québec on
en a parlé avec nos membres en fin de
semaine en toute transparence et on
s'est donné un mandat clair on s'est
donné un plan de match on va partir sur
les routes du Québec dans les prochaines
semaines les prochains mois pour aller à
la rencontre de ces électeurs là pour
aller les écouter parce qu'ils sont
nombreux et nombreuses les gens au
Québec qui ont hésité à voter pour
Québec Solidar il y avait peut-être la
sympathie pour nous mais il y a quelque
chose qui les empêchait vraiment de
mettre leur vote dans l'urne en cochant
Québec solidaire on a eu le mandat de
nos membres de partir en tournée les 11
pour aller à la rencontre des régions du
Québec et bonifier notre offre politique
en vue des élections de 2020 il y a une
perception dans les régions du Québec à
tort ou à raison vous êtes un parti
centré à Montréal comment vous faites
pour vous débarrasser de cette image là
mais d'abord il faut le reconnaître et
on le reconnu en fait semaine en toute
humilité que ça fait partie des défis de
Québec solidaire puis on en reste pas là
on s'est donné les moyens de comprendre
cette perception là puis de la
déconstruire c'est l'objectif qu'on se
donne dans la prochaine année mais
comment vous le faites comment vous êtes
vous êtes vous-même députés sur l'île de
Montréal votre grosse présence elle est
dans la région métropolitaine comment
vous faites pour convaincre à quelqu'un
à cette île que vous êtes en mesure de
bien refléter ses priorités d'abord
monsieur Thibault si on part en tournée
si on va à la rencontre des gens des
régions c'est justement qu'on ne prétend
pas avoir toutes les réponses sinon la
tournée ce serait un exercice de
relation publique qui ce qu'on va mener
c'est un véritable exercice de
consultation on veut entendre les gens
pour vrai on s'en va pas entourer faire
des conférences de presse on s'en va
écouter les gens et bien sûr on a des
pistes de réflexion moi je pense par
exemple qu'il faut que notre proposition
de lutte au changement climatique que
notre plan de match en matière de climat
reflète davantage la réalité des régions
notamment parce que c'est beaucoup les
gens des milieux ruraux qui vivent de
plein fouet les conséquences des
changements climatiques qu'on parle de
l'érosion des berges compare de l'impact
des changements climatiques sur
l'agriculture au Québec il y a moyen de
bonifier notre proposition
environnementale pour qu'elle colle
encore davantage à la réalité
des régions du Québec je pense aussi aux
soins de santé les gens qui sont le plus
victime en ce moment de l'État difficile
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire de
notre système de santé c'est les gens
des régions là on sait tous indignés de
voir une rupture de service à l'urgence
de maison neuve heureusement pas très
loin d'ici il y a quelques semaines
mais les rupture de service comme ça
dans les régions du Québec ça fait des
années que ça se produit et des fois
dans des départements extrêmement
stratégiques comme ceux de l'obstétrique
par exemple je pense que Québec soldat
peut être la voix des gens qui sont
préoccupés par ces enjeux-là mais encore
une fois on a des pistes de réflexion
mais on a pas la prétention d'avoir
toutes les solutions c'est pour ça qu'on
part en tournée dans les prochaines
c'est aussi beaucoup dans les régions
qu'on qu'on utilise des véhicules plus
énergivores qui va ce qui va à
contre-courant de certaines propositions
vous avez faites en campagne électorale
et du capable de réconcilier ça c'est le
défi c'est le défi réconcilier des
mesures ambitieuses de lutte au
changement climatique avec des réalités
qui ne sont pas urbaines on est
conscient de ce défi là je pense qu'on
est d'ailleurs le seul parti politique à
faire un exercice aussi transparent
aussi ouvert et aussi en profondeur de
bilan de nos résultats électoraux nos
collègues des autres formations
politiques je pense n'ont pas fait ce
travail aussi aussi de fonds que celui
fin de semaine en ouvrant d'ailleurs
notre instance au journaliste donc je
pense qu'on fait la preuve de l'humilité
qu'on a Québec solidaire mais aussi de
la détermination parce qu'il s'agit pas
seulement de parler de ce qui s'est mal
passé la dernière fois il s'agit de se
relever les manches de partir sur le
terrain et pour nous ça commence par
séance d'ailleurs cet après-midi c'est
là qu'on va être avec Guillaume Cliche
Rivard sur le terrain dans le sud-ouest
de Montréal pour faire élire un 12e
député de Québec il y a des gens des
observateurs qui ont dit c'est compliqué
de suivre votre message durant la
campagne électorale il y avait des
politiques qui étaient ça semblait un
peu trop difficile vaseux à la limite
est-ce que il y a du travail à faire sur
la façon dont vous exprimez vos idées
envers les électeurs sans aucun doute je
l'ai reconnu à de multiples reprises
depuis le 3 octobre dernier plus une
proposition est compliquée plus elle est
facile à attaquer c'est c'est bien connu
on l'a pas de problème à leur connaître
à Québec solidaire puis les membres nous
ont donné le mandat en fin de semaine de
travailler la prochaine fois à adopter
une plateforme électorale plus concise
réalisable dans un mandat de 4 ans puis
mieux adapté aussi à la conjoncture
politique donc on a fait nos devoirs on
a fait les constats avec lucidité mais
comprenez-moi bien on n'est pas abattu
pour autant on est en ce moment le
deuxième parti au Québec en matière de
don en terme de vote exprimé lors de la
dernière élection on est là pour
talonner François Legault sur la crise
du logement on est là pour talonner
François Legault sur l'environnement on
est là pour être la voix aussi de
l'inclusion au Québec on est là pour
faire valoir notre projet de société et
tout en prenant le temps d'analyser ce
qui s'est passé à l'automne on est
déterminé on est motivé pour l'avenir
puis vous allez nous voir sur le terrain
d'ici la fin de la je vous entends
beaucoup mentionné des éléments avec
lesquels sur lesquels vous avez fait
campagne vos priorités l'environnement
etc est-ce qu'il y a des choses que vous
devez éliminer changer de nouvelles
idées que vous devez amener pour réussir
à percer à l'extérieur de Montréal pour
convaincre les gens de venir devenir
vers vous mais je vais bien honnête avec
vous monsieur Thibault là la plateforme
électorale 2026 de Québec solidaire on
va la faire en 2026 ou en tout cas
peut-être en 2025 on va la faire à ce
moment-là moi en fin de semaine on
rédige pas notre plateforme électorale
pour la prochaine élection on fait le
bilan de ce qui s'est passé le 3 octobre
et on se relève les manches pour dès
maintenant travailler à bonifier notre
projet politique présenter la prochaine
fois une proposition politique est
encore plus collée aux réalités des gens
des régions on n'a pas toutes les
réponses aujourd'hui que vous avez quoi
c'est bien normal on part en tournée
avec nos militants militantes qui sont
d'ailleurs eux et elles déjà partout sur
le territoire déjà enracinés dans toutes
les régions du Québec on va travailler
avec eux avec elle pour présenter en
fait disons une meilleure version de
nous-mêmes la prochaine fois en 2026 et
puis on aura le temps en 2025 2026
autour de là de préparer notre prochaine
campagne électorale Gabriel Ledoux merci
d'avoir été des nôtres ça m'a fait
plaisir